willkommen zu einer neuen sendung von
4cast jetzt unser thema spannend wir
haben lange überlegt sexualität
ja ich möchte die mit einem zitat
beginnt von einer person die ich nicht
kenne aber die im internet vorzufinden
wer sonst war die leute dieses zitat no
pixel ist aber ghana lübeck das hat
einen starken bezug auf das phänomen der
pornografie dass man sich das irgendwie
natürlich anschauen kann
und die frage ist hat das was mit
sexualität zu tun
und ja wir befinden uns in einer zeit wo
das system extrem präsent ist zum
beispiel gibt es nun auch ein fun fact
so dass bestimmte produkte eine gewisse
also mehrere jahre gebraucht haben 50
millionen user zu erlangen da hatten das
flugzeug ewig lang gebraucht ist telefon
hat 30 jahre gebraucht
facebook hat drei jahre gebraucht und 50
millionen user zu bekommen habt diese
plattform hat 19 tage gebraucht dass
dieser statistik findet man im internet
wie genau die sind lässt sich natürlich
bezweifeln
mir schien dort ein kontrakt zwischen
kommunikation also sexualität hat könnte
er was zwischenmenschliches erstmal oder
was auf sich gezogen ist und irgendwie
im internet mit dieser these geht so ein
bisschen weg hin zum konsum zur
einseitigen beziehungen ja ich glaube
dass dieses zitat das kein pixel ein
zurück geben wird na das war also der
besetzung das trifft den punkt ziemlich
gut weil wie du richtig sagt sexualität
eigentlich was zwischenmenschliches ist
oder was selbst bezüglich es ist aber
spielen immer zwei menschen eine rolle
als dialogisches ja die alge
monologischen aber bei dieser pixel
struktur das scheint mir so eine
asymmetrie zu sein
da kommt wirklich nichts zurück
sicherlich auch eine form von sexualität
man muss eben das unterscheiden von
liebe der punkt war ja der der pixel
liebt mehr rück- und dann haben wir noch
einen anderen begriff der sexualität
ja ich würde ihm sagen mit liebe hat das
gewiss nichts zu tun weil da einfach die
dialogische struktur fehlt das ist eine
rein einseitige sache ja und ein anderer
punkt ist es ist mehr eine
konsumorientierte relation und das
liebesverhältnis würde man gewissermaßen
nicht als konsum verhältnis beschreiben
und zwar deswegen weil ja dann das
gegenüber nur ein gegenstand und niemand
der geliebt wird möchte er möchte nicht
den gegenstand geliebt werden dann
möchte auch nicht als gegenstand geliebt
wäre ja nur wegen irgendwelcher
äußerlichkeiten sondern wegen der
innerlichkeit liegen der persönlichkeit
und deswegen glaube ich dass es
sicherlich nichts mit liebe zu tun aber
bestimmt eine form von sexualität
betrifft die durch die entwicklung des
internets ganz neue formen annehmen kann
und dass tatsächlich eine neue form
durchs internet oder sind einfach nur
alte strukturen irgendwie ganz besondere
ausprägungen erleben
juni also ich denke durch dieses massen
angebot worauf du dich auch bezogen hat
mit diesen 50 millionen
durch diese schere quantität und diese
verfügbarkeit die auch wirklich raum
zeitlich losgelöst wieder ist von
ähnlichen printmedien oder zu weisen
glaube ich schon dass wir neue formen
von sexualität oder sexuellen konsum
bekommen der nicht von derselben art ist
wie es die herkömmlichen möglichkeiten
waren da ist führt natürlich zu gewissen
die gefahren sucht internet sucht ja die
natürlich da viel stärker auftreten kann
es gibt sicherlich auch neue formen der
produktiven sexualität durch das
internet war da gibt es ja verschiedene
versuche auch mit robotern bodzek
künstliche intelligenz einzuführen da
ist immer noch ganz am anfang kann man
nicht absehen wohin das führen wird und
siehst du daran irgendetwas schlechtes
wie alles im internet daher handelt es
sich um zwei seiten es gibt
schattenseiten es gibt nicht sein wenn
man sich dieser medien kritisch bedient
stichwort medienkompetenz
dann gibt es da viel zu entdecken im
internet
die gefahr ist eben die dass man fehlte
privatheit hat dass daten nach außen
dringen und dass man auch gewissermaßen
abhängig wird von diesem medium und dass
man nicht mehr im wirklichen leben sind
angesichts angesichts kommuniziert und
das auch die körperlichkeit ja im
internet keine rolle
die raum zeitlich verschiedene logik ich
glaube zu sexualität oder zuliebe auf
jeden fall gehörten immer eine
körperliche seite die wir durch robotik
das editieren oder simulieren können ich
weiß aber nicht ob wir körperlichkeit
auch durch virtuelle realität neu
erzeugen können ich glaube dass es sich
dabei nur um simulationen hoffe nicht
dass das eine herausforderung die noch
mit der vorstellung bedient eine
thematik der sexualität des internets
oder sexualität der digitalität
digitalisierung ist ein ganz neues
forschungsgebiet wo sich die
soziologinnen und soziologen die
psychologin psychologe und die
philosophen und philosophen noch ihre
köpfe zerbrechen müssen
ok danke für das kurze interview über
dieses thema als das spannende thema und
kontrovers wahrscheinlich auch wenn
irgendwelche punkte gerne in die
kommentare
wir sind sehr interessiert darüber zu
sprechen bis dann und bis zu einer
nächsten folgen tschüss